I'm worried about my espresso machine
I'm not
oh that can be your headlight
it's not a joke it's just I'm worried
about my Lane
in a
um
just exploded I'm talking about getting
rid of the machine felt him down and
turned him into prison bars I'm not a
lawyer the lawyers are lawyers the
lawyers are lawyers the lawyers the
lawyers get rid of the machines I've
talked about getting rid of the machine
just pillows who did this attack who did
the Cyber attack so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but here's
what my attorney said he said
um
do you frequently go to Hardee's is that
a common place you go okay that's pretty
funny
that could be your headline the machine
I said I would have passed through him
and went to find a ride through it's
really incredible The Branding around
that is she said no you're not giving my
phone I said arrest me I've done nothing
wrong you should know we're not gonna
arrest you I said well you can do
anything and you
getting rid of the machine oh
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
effectively
your daughter want me to me
as highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
well it's a very special day because we
have today returning to the program Mike
Lindell CEO and inventor of my pillow
what
what would you like me to say David
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
what's so hard to understand
[Music]
they can pull these names it's just like
every state every state has people that
voted that don't live in the states hold
it David you're doing the population of
Wisconsin I have a moral compass who
million you can get them I did I got
requests out to every single these are
right on the voter rolls David you're
not listening
[Music]
get rid of my espresso machine the
voting machine David everything that can
be packed you got you know credit cards
companies get hacked businesses act gas
companies act who did this attack who
did this Cyber attack that's all I'm
about we can't have computers running
our election Mike you've mentioned so
much let me just make one comment here
nope nope nope melt them down and turn
them into prison
[Music]
bars.com
when you have a computer you can change
one number you can do anything you hack
in and you can expect Millions where if
you had to do the same thing with paper
you'd have to have a ball of people you
asked me the dumb question about getting
rid of machines if you want to be a
humorous interview get rid of my
espresso machine all right
[Music]
what I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are
lawyers
I'm not a lawyer the lawyers are lawyers
yeah
um
[Music]
hear it from you should have one of my
pillows too we are gonna take a moment
to recover here from the extremely high
level of energy
I could talk to you all day about this
well welcome everybody it is indeed CPAC
day two kind of day one because day one
was canceled I streamed last night and
like they just didn't televise any of it
it's all very weird they're of course
also either running very late or it's
all out of order uh so let's see where
we are and then we have so many
different things to talk about Clips to
look at I have video from outside CPAC
and it's just gonna blow your mind
um this is already a very glitchy stream
so I'll refresh it and see if we can uh
why why is it so glitchy it's all crazy
but anyway we've got a different stream
here from right side broadcasting that
look at look at how pathetic this stream
is
let's see if we turn no it's not even a
question of turning it down it's it's
just all horrifyingly pathetic
um okay so I know that Rick Scott spoke
and just finished now he was supposed to
be done by 310 so he was like 40 minutes
late
but things may be completely out of
order the next thing was going to be a a
panel I guess you would call it with
Mercedes schlapp the wife of um match
lap who is accused of pummeling the junk
of uh an intern it's insane
um they were going to do a thing about
you know parents with pitchforks like
parents for freedom of Education or
whatever it is they're talking about at
some point later they were going to have
a mass
saved
um and then what we're really here for
of course are some of these later events
Matt schlapp and Chris Reddy will be
speaking Mike Pompeo Eric Schmidt and
today's keynote is the complete and
total a dangerous lunatic Candace Owens
who recently suggested a eugenics-like
breeding program to be better at math we
covered that on the program
uh not long ago let's listen a little
bit to what right side broadcasting is
saying and then we have so many things
here to talk about this one in my
backpack not gonna lie so did I okay
okay I um I learned how to play
I always call it a blackjack yeah
Blackjack and
I was using my friend's cash and I went
through like 200 of hers that's a good
friend electric commentary here by right
side broadcasting and we'll keep
monitoring all of it
um looks like this fell off live okay
we're standing by for the next thing and
that should be happening very very soon
let's get to a couple of different
things just since since everybody's here
I see comments saying David wait are you
back in the old Studio
in a sense the old studio is now just my
office so it's still available people
thought I might have given the panels
back to Sam seder but I didn't I kept
them this it's like now my office but
it's still available and we were doing
work in the office today so it's it's
all it's all still happening but I am
not in the new studio at this exact
moment in time I don't think it'll
affect us too significantly
um let's see what's going on here as far
as uh super chats go
there we go I think I think we're good
as far as that goes will I open the
phone lines today
um I will absolutely open the phone
lines today if we get to a hundred
website members and twitch subscribers I
see some people in the chat saying that
I'm being callous about sexual assault
folks I am not even remotely callous
about sexual assault it is a physical
difficulty to not smirk a little when
you hear the serve pummeled my junk it's
just a funny term there's nothing funny
about sexual assault match slap if he's
if if he is guilty of five percent of
what he was accused of he's disgusting
okay but you try to do a show and say
pummeled pummeled my junk without
laughing it's genuinely difficult okay
it is not even remotely minimizing the
substance of it here's the panel on
something about parents are angry I do
want to say thanks to Lee Lee MW
Lucia fur Sam the sleaze bag shoplifting
empath and nasty questions kicking us
off-putting us at five a big thank you
to Anthony labor pool who just signed up
on my website today's coupon code is
CPAC trash I don't think that one
requires much explanation here is
Mercedes schlap let's listen to uh what
parents are now their parents are angry
they're doing things okay
with Olivia she's actually a school
board member down in drippings Springs
Texas and I want to ask you why would
you run to be a school board member you
came to CPAC and really got your
training and you said I got to make a
difference so this is another example of
a person who got involved when they came
to CPAC and made a difference in their
Community wow I ran really because of
2020. I mean masks were really the it
for me I'm so blessed my son's receiving
an excellent education we have a
wonderful District but 2020 kind of
opened the veil of what we what we stand
to lose and what's at risk if parents
start losing rights so I got really
involved parents rights have been taken
away morning work I love it we have a
lot to do but 2020 was really it I never
in a million years so you're saying
covid covered lockdown seeing the kids
suffer yeah incrementally the shutdowns
I understood immediately what that was
going to do to kids emotionally socially
not being in school the stress the that
put on families I saw my own son regress
but for me it was really The Masks
because the masks were the point that I
would have pulled out of public schools
right you know the masks seem like the
smallest concern like the biggest
problem was just social isolation and
then no exposure to pathogens at all
where now you see all these you know
kids who now are like in their first
year at college and they're sick for
three months because they have no
immunity to anything from having been
you know like it happened to my sister
that's the masks seem like a very
irrelevant thing you are
the messenger when it comes to school
choice in Virginia you all
of Virginia to figure out
how do we get parents to be able to be
empowered to send their kids to the best
schools that they want that that would
be the Parents Choice how do you get
this process going well first of all
we've got to get people elected who want
parents to be able to have the choice to
send their children to whatever school
that they want I mean this is like a
no-brainer these children are mine they
don't belong to the state and I am these
are hurt
my kids we don't co-parent these are my
kids and so I want to be able to make
that choice for my children and I want
everybody to have that choice and
unfortunately there are too many of
these politicians who are listening to
the teachers unions which by the way
they don't care as much as they you know
they they say they do because here's I
think that this panel may actually save
our kids news because you stop paying
your dues and you see how quickly they
keep you in the Union right right so
this is all about the dues and we're
saying children ought to be able to have
a hope and a future and the way that
starts is with a good education without
a good education you get nowhere and you
get there very fast there are people who
are incarcerated sixty percent of them
are functionally illiterate that's what
we're the school to prison pipeline has
already started we've got to stop that
well I gotta ask you uh lieutenant
governor you know you're talking about
should we be for the students or should
we be for the teachers unions
that's another no-brainer right
um this is about children right and
their future we we've already had our
education and we don't want our children
to say to us what did you do to make
sure that I would have a good education
what did you do and and and we've just
got to stay involved right for those of
us who are not involved we've got to get
involved because if we keep doing the
same things you know what that means and
we get the same results then we are part
of the problem too and the reason why we
won in Virginia uh number one was
because
parents and it didn't matter if they
were Republican the reason they won in
Virginia was by pretending everything
was about critical race Theory which
wasn't actually being taught to anyone
that's how they won in this
egg lines Ian Pryor is one of the front
line Fighters when it comes to making
sure that they don't push for that the
school districts don't push real
principled fighter what did he do take a
mask off to indoctrinate our children
and he is also the author of the book
parents of the World Unite how to save
our schools from the less radical agenda
and the first line says
the first sign says if you're reading
this book chances are you're interested
in starting a parent's revolution in
your own School District or neighborhood
give us a gist of what's in this book
why did you write it well antifa must be
handling the audio at this event rose up
in in Virginia and and we organized and
we did a good job organizing it took a
lot of work from a lot of people that
put a lot of time in all right so listen
I think we get the point the parents are
angry the parents have lost rights the
parents want freedom
okay so after this we will then have
uh some tough mother is coming up next
with moms so we're going from I guess
it's just a lot of mom stuff
and then later they'll talk about
euthanasia I got some it's it's all
pretty horrifying it's all pretty
horrifying so let's continue monitoring
this
um and see what's on people's minds to
some degree Gustavo says to with today's
first Super Chat David sir out of
curiosity can you speak Brazilian
Portuguese no no I cannot
um just I'm just not able to I'm not
able to do it even under duress I would
not be able to do it uh thanks to
crowbars forever for re-upping the
twitch Prime subscription very much
appreciate it let's look at a couple of
other Clips here of different things
that have been going on uh around CPAC
here's an interesting video from outside
CPAC which I know my audience will find
fascinating
and they let you and they let you cross
Interstate borders to get here I just
want to make sure sir
and tell us about the group down in
Texas we got about a minute tell us
about that group I created this group
back in the summer of 2020.
okay so really just heroic really heroic
stuff happening there
um here is JP right JD Mandel hold on do
I even have it here let me check my
glitch folder
we've endorsed JP right JD Mandel here's
JD Mandel speaking proudly that the very
thing that makes this country special is
that whether you're powerful or not
whether you're rich or poor we all have
equal justice under law or at least we
did until Joe Biden's gang of thugs
moved into the White House
when the thugs moved into the White
House it all um it all went away it was
just it was horrible what what happened
when when that took place uh here is Joe
Biden asked when will you announce your
re-election sir
all right very clear uh crystal clear in
fact I would say and then here is
Candace Owens this is tonight's um
keynote it's the she's the prime speaker
I guess for today's day of CPAC here she
is talking about who she would like to
punch in the face it might surprise you
it's not neo-nazis it's not child
abusers nope
it's zelensky yep take a listen to
zelenski warning you of what will happen
if you stop funding his lifestyle
the U.S will have to send their sons and
daughters exactly the same way as we are
sending their sons and daughters to war
and they will have to fight because it's
a nature that we're talking about and
they will be dying God forbid because
it's a horrible thing okay oh
oof I am not going to say that I'd like
to punch funky in the face because
that's that's violent but I am saying
that if I could get away with punching
one person in the face and have no
consequences it would be president
zielinski I can't even tell you how much
oof I Harbor for him the audacity to
tell you that the consequence is going
to be that your sons and daughters are
going to fight and die if you don't help
him secure a win against Russia that's
not even really what he said man so this
is the revered keynote speaker who will
be speaking to us later today at CPAC so
that should really be a treat BW Rock
Says via Super Chat Trump is speaking
Saturday for people that are asking yeah
speaking of education did you see Jamie
raskin's grammar lessons on the use of
pronouns and nouns we all need to do
this when we hear Democrat cities yeah
it's pretty good
um let me pull it up for people if you
haven't seen it it really is good let me
see if I can find it Raskin
Democrat democratic
um let's see if I can find it
yeah this is really good Jamie raskin's
great big big big fan he's been a guest
on the show and just all around good guy
just a brief semantic point because the
gentle lady was making a grammatical
error that I heard some of her
colleagues make before I believe she
referred to a Democrat solution I heard
another member talk about a Democrat
member and a Democrat plan I just wanted
to educate our distinguished colleagues
that Democrat is the noun when you use
it as an adjective you say the
Democratic member or the Democratic
solution or the Democratic plan and so I
assume it's a good faith grammatical
error the first few times but after
people were corrected several times and
they continue to say it it seems like
it's an act of incivility yes as if
every time we mentioned the other party
it just came out with a kind of
political speech impediment like oh the
Banana Republican party as if we were to
say that every time we mentioned the
Banana Republican member or the Banana
Republican plan or the Banana Republican
conference but we wouldn't do that so
out of pure political courtesy when it's
an adjective refer to the democratic
congresswoman or the Democratic member
having said that I'd like to say that I
favor the bobert amendment I think it's
really the Raskin Amendment because none
of them apparently caught the fact that
their reporting requirement wasn't to be
published all right you I think we get
the point so a very very well said there
by Jamie Raskin pointing out the
absurdity of that Daniel says walked
into an adult novelty store accidentally
and saw they were out of caucaswords a
very in demand item yeah this this is my
favorite clip potentially of the Year
this was Vernon Jones trying to hearken
back to the racist ideology of the 1780s
about three races caucasoid
and negroid and he failed to even say
them correctly and he coined two
exciting new terms which are mono gourd
and a sword this is what he said
yesterday look at this he said I'm a
what at this church I'm a white boy but
I'm not stupid Vernon I mean
let me drop back for a second first of
all Jason my good friend uh being Latino
is no race there's only three races
monogor Conquest sword
monagord and caucasword any monogords in
my audience anybody anybody at all
looks like a couple
two three okay any cauca swords in my
audience
everybody okay yeah most people are
saying I'm a caucus sword yep
it's it's so deranged oh Jason my good
friend uh being Latino is no race
there's only three racing monogor
conquer sword and negroid but liberals
create this whole new class or a new
race called Latinos they are no race and
it is it is very clear he did say that
that Hispanics are more diverse in their
thinking than African-American not
diverse in where they from come from as
a matter of fact Spaniards have nothing
to do with Mexicans and they all speak
the same I mean other than like
conquering and you know it in
interbreeding language but again
liberals created this race if you and
made it unique based on you speaking uh
Hispanic I speak Hispanic you speak
Hispanic they speak Hispanic very very
exciting really at the Forefront of a
racial scholarship there Vernon Jones as
you can see Trump endorsed that guy
Trump endorsed that guy all right let's
go back to a little bit of this panel
about all of the rights that parents are
losing I want to say thanks to Andrew
D'Angelo for signing up at
joinpakman.com folks with peace and love
today's coupon code is CPAC trash CPAC
trash if we get to 100 website members
and twitch subscribers we will again
open the phone lines I also want to say
thanks to caretaker 909 whose new member
number 14 today this feed very very
glitchy but this one is good let's
listen I will say that there the the
scope of the law may be changing here in
the fourth circuit which is where we are
there was a case Grimm versus Gloucester
County School Board which the fourth
circuit two judges with one dissenting
held that a student has the equal
protection right to use the bathroom of
the gender that they identify with which
creates a lot of problems when you're in
the fourth circuit because they will you
know a student will say well I have have
this equal protection right but at the
end of December the 11th circuit federal
court of appeals in a 7-4 decision said
well not in the 11th circuit so in the
11th circuit they held that Title IX
says that if you have sex segregated
bathrooms they must be sex segregated on
biological sex and there is no equal
protection right to use a bathroom that
does not correspond with your biological
sex now we all know there have been so
many problems with bathrooms the the
country over it's just there's constant
instances of uh you know harassment and
assault and epithets and all it's it's
just it's been such a problem in in blue
states that just say just use whatever
bathroom corresponds to your gender
identity it's just police reports
hundreds
oh wait there have been no issues
whatsoever hmm
maybe this isn't really that big of a
problem not support support their child
and their gender fluidity and the child
wants puberty blockers right and that's
that that was the bill she introduced in
2020 in the Virginia legislature so
effectively if you as a parent do not
agree with whatever your child is is
saying and you don't take her to the
clinic to get puberty blockers or
cross-sex hormones or to get surgery or
you just don't even let her identify at
school as a boy you can be investigated
by child protective services and
arrested okay is that happening no
the other thing is they like to mix all
of this stuff together they're like oh
you know bathrooms surgeries
and arrests and crimes and drag queens
and all these it's like wait hold on
let's back it up a second you know there
are no that we just the bathroom thing
is not a problem it no matter what
gender identity you adhere to it's
illegal to go into a bathroom or locker
room and photograph people you can't
harass people you can't sexually assault
people so like okay that's one issue
secondly they go oh prepubescent girls
are having their breasts chopped off
prepubescent girls don't have breasts
what are you chopping off doesn't make
any sense
we then get to puberty blockers now
listen let's be very honest about this
there is a question as to what are the
long-term effects of puberty blockers
even if only temporarily there are
questions about the impact on rates of
osteoporosis and bone density among
girls eventually women who take puberty
bloggers let's look at that of course we
why wouldn't we look at that but don't
wrap it up with bathrooms
don't wrap it up with crimes
don't wrap it up with with you know
surgeries arrests of parents it they
don't whether these people understand
what's going on or not
they know their audience
certainly doesn't understand it and
that's why they continue to repeat these
obviously untrue narratives your state
representatives are ensuring that for
state level lieutenant governor let me
ask you as you you've encountered the
obviously the opposition from Democrats
but you've also run into a problem with
Republicans and kind of their strange
relationship with some teacher unions
what what is happening well sometimes
you know unfortunately people get afraid
of the teachers unions because they're
huge and they can work against you but
the reason why we we do things as John F
Kennedy said it's not because they're
easy it's because they're hard and I
would add it's because they're righteous
and if I have to lose the next election
so that the children can get an
opportunity for a good education I'll do
it because children need a future you
know it's not about maintaining a seat
it's about our children and their future
and without you know Abraham Lincoln
there
identifying as monogords all over the
state of Virginia operation is the
philosophy of the classroom
in the government
think about that and and so that's why
we have to keep fighting and I would put
it to you that this is the new Brown
versus Board of Education fight
this is what it's all about parents
parents again being able to choose where
their children should be able to go to
school right right and so that's like
the full circle which is we want charter
schools and we want a voucher with which
you can choose to defund defund defund
Public Schools a little bit at a time if
that's what you so choose has nothing to
do with gender identity in reality has
nothing to do with CRT or wokeness or
black history courses or any of it what
they really want at the end of the day
is how can we find any way to weaken
public education and then later of
course they complain we're really not
that good at math
you're all you're doing is weakening
education how could we possibly be good
at math if that's the case Austin says
via Super Chat David sir when is the
next DPAC
maybe we could have a panel on whether
it's a a historian or an historian it
would be more useful than CPAC it
absolutely would be more useful than
CPAC we still have Mike Pompeo who's
going to speak we have Candace Owens
um some people call her Candace blowens
because she's just full of hot air just
blowing hot air all over the place
worthless worthless nonsense I do want
to say thank you to deeper shades of
house elevated disc golf Emily Bowflex
man all who have just re-upped twitch
Prime subscriptions putting us at 18.
today you can use the coupon code CPAC
trash to get a dramatically discounted
membership on my website joinpakman.com
hit that red sign up button it's an
amazing amazing thing I'll keep shouting
out people who do let me set see what
else I had here that I wanted to go over
um do I have anything else to say about
the Glenn Greenwald attacks on me no I
on yesterday's stream
I did a segment about Glenn Greenwald
and Brianna Joy gray going after me
since that segment Brianna Joy gray has
deleted her tweet about me but we
screenshotted it we have it and then I
did a segment today on it I don't know
that I really have more to say it was
all about Marianne uh Williamson and my
commentary about it all right this panel
thankfully is over
and uh the next panel what is next on
the agenda according to this the next
panel is some tough mother
with Sandy Rios lunatic Penny Nance from
concerned women for America dangerous
pathetic group Abby Johnson from of and
then there were none no idea who that is
and Kimberly Fletcher from moms for
America so the moms very soon are going
to let us know what they think and and
it's going to be uh I'm sure I'm sure
very very powerful thanks to Nikki for
the twitch Prime subscription appreciate
that let's I've been meaning to
oh hold on where are we at on this
um
oh yeah okay voicemails let's do a
couple oh actually you know what they're
starting this pretty quick let's listen
I do want to see how crazy this panel is
all right
let it fall off well good afternoon I'm
going to take issue with disastrous
audio I mean just absolutely a joke it's
the best panel Right girls right yeah
all right that's right you have to do
what we're talking about do you based on
the title I thought that title threw me
but we're actually talking about today
defending uh human dignity now think
about that if you were going to talk
about that what would you say well of
course I'm supposed to lead the panel so
I had to kind of think about this but
it's interesting to the left they don't
even know what the panel's about
um their definition of it is it has to
do with wealth and position like think
of Downton Abbey dignified dignity and
so it's they think they discovered human
dignity the real meaning of it in 1948
with the UN Declaration of Human Rights
but they forgot that there was this
thing called the Declaration of
Independence we hold these truths
self-evident that all men are created
equal and they're endowed by their
creator with certain and alienable
rights it we are we are uh there's
dignity dignity comes from our worth and
it comes from God ultimately if you
believe in God and most of us do
certainly all of us on this panel and
they also most of us several centuries
earlier than that something went like
this in the Bible in Christ there is
neither Jew nor Greek slave nor free
male nor female all at one in Christ
it's all the same so it was actually
God's idea I thought I'd mention that
and he is the one who makes us
creates Us in His image and gives us a
certain worth and dignity so
then what does that mean for now when I
was thinking about this I thought about
the ways that we have lost
our dignity and I just thought I would
just Supply a few that you might
remember then does anyone remember covid
does anybody remember the way people
treated each other about masking donate
plasma today please does anybody have
anything inside the family on account of
that was there anything just hit the
body with a tremendous system very
powerful life has anybody watched the
Academy Awards or Super Bowl Halftime
lately or did you keep your children
away from it because it was
beneath dignity it was not what God had
in mind when he created us in His image
how about social media how about those
posts that are so vitriolic that they
dehumanize and Destroy most of those
posts are from her side of bodies that
God created in His image through
transgender surgeries how about that
oh God and how about the district
disrespect of human life CPAC 1950 is
where we are of dignity the loss of
human dignity so our panelists are going
to talk about this in different ways and
I think first of all go to Abby because
Abby as you know her story is that she
was a Planned Parenthood director and
left because she actually had to help on
an abortion that's if you don't know her
story I wanted you to know this so Abby
abortion is something that you know a
great deal about more than probably most
of us so in what ways do you see now in
the practice of abortion whatever it is
the loss of human dignity
well I think we're seeing it greatly
right now in our country with the
expansion of medication abortion in
particular
our current Administration Biden almost
all abortions have been medication
abortions for a really long time
actually
with the expansion of medication
abortion into all pharmacies across this
country
you know I'm not sure that we really
know what all the ramifications are
going to be because of that we're
talking about women going well people
who seek an abortion will hopefully be
able to do that safely would be the the
primary repercussion any sort of medical
supervision taking these pills not
really knowing what's going to happen to
their bodies not really understanding
what's going to happen inside of their
womb they're passing these babies into
the toilet it's pretty damn well
understood actually what happens Nancy
possibly hemorrhaging in their bathroom
unable to get to an emergency care
facility looking in by the way a lot of
the Emergency Care Facilities they talk
about are just places where they
convince you not to get an abortion
what do I do with this fully formed baby
what do I do with this child
do I scoop this child up out of the
toilet do I take this child to be buried
what do I do with it do I do I flush my
child down the toilet these people are
truly sick these These are disgusting
people
um I I know that to some in the audience
you might be saying what what the hell
is happening here
this is
um standard standard anti-abortion
rhetoric scare mongering
um acting as though extraordinarily safe
medications are unsafe uh it's it's that
this is what they do this is what they
do this it's quite literally nonsense
country
and the the left will say
I would say that
um creating
abortion facilities in every woman's
home I would say that uh
I would say that flushing babies down
the toilets
because of these chemical abortions I
would say that this is not progress
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times all right I couldn't resist I
couldn't resist these people are sick
okay and they've lost the country
more than at any time since Roe v Wade
Americans are generally speaking for
abortion being legal
in most cases so they've lost on this
it's just it's not even close they've
lost on this
um
t-i-g-q says via an extremely powerful
super chat what's the difference between
the Republican National Convention and
CPAC a CPAC is not organized by the
Republican party that's the main
difference
why does CPAC go to other countries that
I couldn't tell you it's it is a very
strange thing a thanks to hallowed
grounds for re-upping your Twitch Prime
subscription your number 20 today huge
thank you to Johnny Minogue and Taryn
Erickson for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com we're here for the next
several hours there are a number of
unhinged dangerous and ignorant speakers
tonight and they will only get more
unhinged and ignorant as the days go
culminating with uh what I can only
expect to be a uh very strange confused
speech from Donald Trump on Saturday
last night was day one even though they
kind of like canceled it but we still
did a stream and we opened phone lines I
will open phone lines again today if we
simply get to 100 members and twitch
subscribers we're we've we're at 22 out
of 100 percentage-wise let me see what
that is
2 divided by 10 would be 0.2 and then 0.
and then 2 divided by 10
24 of the way there I think we are is 22
out of 124 percent of the way it's it's
it is hard to do it just in intuitively
like that women and looks at women I
mean talk
talk about sexism
better than women including being women
what is sex Sizzle it's a Levine as you
know the the woman of the year by USA
Today right or you know Chelsea Clinton
just wrote a children's book and
recognized Rachel Levine who is the the
Bine Administration appointee who's a
biological man
um you know they've done everything they
can possibly do to take away the
trophies and the scholarships for women
the few little set-asides that we have
in businesses concerned women for
America knows what a woman is
and so do the American people and
apparently we need to tell our president
but we've got to stand up for the
dignity and the unique Dignity of
American women you know I want to answer
that I thank you that's wonderful I want
to add a counter to that you know one of
the things I've not maybe people in the
audience have an answer to this
they are they're obsessed with you know
use the bathroom that aligns with your
birth genitalia assuming you were not
born intersex okay fine so we'll put
intersex out of it use the bathroom that
aligns with your birth genitalia
do they think that it makes sense for
someone like for example Blair white
look up Blair white if you don't know
who she is
are they saying the logical thing to
keep everybody calm and to keep
everything low-key is for Blair white to
use a men's room like is that I've not
seen any of them actually address that
question because that doesn't make any
sense right I mean what what it what
actually is it that they think should
happen in in uh the those situations in
those circumstances I've not heard a
single one of these people actually
answer that it just doesn't really make
any sense
well I think you want to see chaos right
I mean to some degree I'm kind of joking
here and being tongue-in-cheek you want
to see chaos send Blair white into the
men's room right well and supreme and
and what their orchaz Bono reverse yeah
absolutely to us as as women as moms
they're they've been very successful in
in replacing fathers with the government
and and what they're doing is trying to
steal the hearts and minds of our
children because they have a whole new
world they're creating and they know
historically that's what you do that's
what Hitler did that's what Mao did
that's why here we go you take the
children you win the future so we as
parents have got to stand up first of
all we have to know what's what's coming
our way if you guys think that you know
what's happening in the classrooms
just have a smidgen of what's happening
in the classrooms it would make your
skin crawl to know what our children are
being exposed to and and the irony of
the fact that we have parents who are
mothers who are going into these school
districts reading we have parents who
are mothers that's really the Revelation
against women against children it's
violence it's aggressiveness it's
everything that is anti-humane and
they're they're exposed to these things
the parents come and read them in the
school board meetings and we have moms
that are literally being handcuffed
because you the school board members are
saying you can't say that here it's on
public TV all right very good so we've
got a sense of this panel now let's
continue to check out what's next
Apparently after this there's going to
be it just says mass now I don't know if
that means Catholic mass oh no no okay
so that's in a different room so in the
main Ballroom we're going to have oh no
God Stephen Moore Stephen Moore is truly
horrible he's now the co-founder of the
committee to unleash Prosperity dear God
so that's coming up next and then a
couple later it'll be Matt schlapp with
Chris Ruddy I mentioned yesterday it's
so funny Chris Ruddy the CEO of Newsmax
has privately sent me messages telling
me he really likes what I do I'm not
claiming he's a liberal or anything it's
just kind of like a little interesting
behind the scenes uh trivia sort of
thing
um okay couple things J Cole who just
re-upped a YouTube membership for 10
months love your show been following you
for many years laughed cried and enjoyed
the band you're so glad you were growing
thank you J Cole great to have you here
always great to see you I want to say
thanks to chunky strudel in deciso
Copper Bunny and pilot dog for re-upping
twitch Prime subscriptions also Jeff
fahena Jeff fahena with the twitch Prime
subscription number 27 and remember we
have the coupon code CPAC trash in all
seriousness you all know January and
February have been very tough uh from
the standpoint of YouTube because of
what's going on with that January 9th
cataclysmic event I won't explain it
again but uh we really are extra
dependent right now on people who go to
the website hit that sign up button the
website is joinpakman.com coupon code
CPAC trash it's an insane coupon code
okay just an absolute look at this and
you can also do monthly I will shout
everybody out
also that directly funds directly funds
the Spanish Channel which is now at
nearly 2 000 subscribers we're doing our
content in Spanish for the
Spanish-speaking Community hard to think
of a more important thing to do right
now especially given the role that
Florida is going to play in the 2024
election so a lot of really really
really important things happening
um and then what else did I have
okay will I take phone calls if we get
to a hundred website members and twitch
subscribers we will open the phone lines
we had some great uh phone calls
yesterday and uh oh couple of voicemails
yeah let's do just a couple of
voicemails
real quick just because you know we
still have them we still have them
um
uh a lot of these are not very good I
have to tell you but let me play like
one
voicemail
hey David I hate to be that guy but um
on your segment yesterday on yesterday's
show uh regarding uh Candace Owens
talking about breeding children uh to be
better at math
um you mentioned that you know many of
her colleagues wanted to
um abolish the department of energy I
think you meant to say the Department of
Education I did that was a mistake I
think I we've been talking about the
Department of Education in the context
of that covid report
I meant in the context of Candace's
breeding Eugenics idea I met the
Department of Education not the
department of energy and I am always
glad always glad to be corrected on
those issues
um let's see what else we have here
uh okay let's just go back to this for a
little bit media be bold be loud be
offensive if you have to use your voice
all right
I love my sisters here and you're right
fight every single day but I do want to
give you a little glimmer of hope what I
namely wolf who uh is I think she's
Jewish she used to be an atheist you're
worth this beautiful piece on substack
that I was reading this morning this is
like someone who doesn't understand
she's Jewish but she used to be an
atheist this is someone who doesn't even
understand what Judaism is Christian
Nation
there are no vacuums something will fill
it and she talks about how the old
religions the old gods Baal and Malik
the god of death are moving in and we're
seeing it we're seeing it right now and
it is satanic but the truth is that's
mental illness it's considered
legitimate political discourse by many
in this country that is a mentally ill
thing to say it is it is a paranoid
delusion
and there are psychiatrists who would
try to medicate that belief you're
seeing it happen all over this country
last year Liberty University same thing
the holy spirit is alive and well and
where there is Satan God is stronger
amen and so we lean into that but we're
not letting anybody off the hook
everybody here has to fight tell the
truth be loud go to your go to your
school board meetings stand in front of
the clinics and invite young women to
have a better solution invite them to
your home care for the least of these
excellent Kimberly can you keep it to a
minute yes I will keep it really simple
women are the ones destroying this
country women are the ones who can
repair it we as conservative Women of
Faith have not been voting we've not
been actively engaging in our
communities we haven't paid attention to
what's happening in our school board in
our school and our classrooms and the
whole entire time those who are trying
to destroy them I thought it was Satan
that was destroying the country the the
previous lady said it's Satan and this
woman says it's women destroying it we
need she's right there is no void that
just it doesn't just stay there we need
to fill it back up with all the good
things that's the true story of America
the story of their birth the children
that they love that let's give them back
the things that they have lost all we
need to really complete this event is
this
over the years that's just raising
worshiping right now yeah gladly
we appreciate it thank you
thank you Jesus
[Music]
folks that's not Italian I will warn you
know
I know you probably didn't notice but
that's not actually happening at CPAC
that was that's a different video of uh
someone speaking in tongues Eugene says
via a very generous Super Chat David sir
I prefer clandus Owens to Candace
blowens okay well we I will take all of
those names under advisement thanks to
Peter Parker and Sterling LA or Sterling
Lana and Napoleon blown a party for the
twitch Prime subscriptions that puts us
at 30 also a huge thing listen to folks
look at what these people are doing on
my website Patricia Ferguson just signed
up with the code CPAC trash Robert
LaPlace just used the code Beau Paulsen
just used the code and Aaron held
signing up with the coupon code CPAC
trash on my website putting us at 34. we
may have the phones open before they
even complete one exorcism and we lack
the worth he gives it already but to
reclaim it and act upon it and so with
that how did we do
how do we do it okay good oh which 28th
sex left
well I can I just throw up one thing we
determine the level of humanity there's
only one thing missing from this panel
and we will be and Men of humanity that
we have right now let's we as women be
the best that we can be Rise Up Lift the
culture and bring back the human dignity
that we need in our country good good
and act like
um act worthy of the calling don't
degrade yourselves yeah like by
appearing on panels like this stop to
great with your language
reclaim that Grace that greatness that
God has given you at your birth reclaim
that and I think you're absolutely right
Kimberly with that we are out of time so
thank you so much
another incredible panel Jabba dahat via
Super Chat says ready for the lunacy
well we're seeing it the Herman Cain
award says all these nicknames for
Candace Owens are silly when everyone
knows it's blackface Tomi Lauren that's
that's pretty that's pretty aggressive
um
uh okay let's see what is coming up next
next is Stephen Moore talking about
health care which I'm sure will be
extraordinarily informative and that's
uh that'll be
that'll be next I guess or something uh
okay
shorty has re-upped a YouTube
subscription and says sir I missed you
well it's great to be back two days in a
row of streaming for the first time in
months and then we are hopefully going
to go to number three in a row tomorrow
and four in a row on Saturday a lot of
questions about what's going on with the
mustache I am ready and willing to move
to the next phase of the facial hair we
will eventually get all the way back to
the beginning in my mind the next phase
of the facial hair is a goatee
um now
I will go to that next I don't know when
I don't know when but we're gonna go to
that next and uh people are angry about
it or people like it and all these
different things I don't care okay we're
just it's a it's a process it's a
process we've done the mustache for a
few weeks we're next going to be going
to the goatee and that'll start I don't
know at some point Michelle frateroli
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code CPAC trash and his new
member number 35 today very much
appreciate that how many subscriptions
for a half mustache
okay here's the deal I will make
if we get to 250 subscriptions today I
will do tomorrow's stream with half a
mustache I will shave half the mustache
and do tomorrow's stream with half a
mustache and I know it'll cause all sort
of satanic panic and all of that stuff
but we will uh we will look into doing
that if that is the case John Hickey
welcome John Hickey our newest member on
the website using the coupon code CPAC
trash as well and uh Jen here gifting a
subscription on Twitch which I very much
appreciate I believe that the next
session is with Stephen Moore and it is
about health care my guess is he will
talk about how great for-profit health
care is I don't know
um but that's just my prediction welcome
hippie chick thanks for the twitch Prime
subscription
Nick Butler says David sir please bless
us with Trump audio glitches yeah I've
got some Trump uh let's see where are
the audio glitches hold on
you know Mike did me on 60 Minutes
that's not it hold on where is it
where are the audio glitches
uh
don't know that I can find them here
man where are those audio glitches I'll
have to look for those let's listen to
this great panel first really the
architect of the tax plan and so to miss
Donald Trump come on let's face it was
he great or what
Phil carpin who is a true warrior on
this issue and many others who is head
of American commitment and we're gonna
we're gonna get right into it today
so over the last 10 years you know what
have we been talking about with health
care it's been Obamacare it's about
repeal and replace it's about getting
drug prices down and what president
Trump tried to do and I served at HHS
and secretary Azar tried hard to get
those drug prices down mandates he tried
really hard but failed but what a lot of
people haven't really focused on is what
happened right before the election which
was this IRA and the drug pricing and
Health Care Provisions in there passed
by the Democrats and their interest
groups So today we're going to talk
about one of those interest groups and
talk about that Ira mislabeled the
inflation uh reduction act with our
friends here so let's start with Phil
Phil you know most people see that ARP
is the group that has that nice slick
magazine that has the discounts for
seniors they've sort of transformed
themselves though into this marketing
entity with a advocacy arm and they they
make a lot of money from their
relationships tell us about these
royalties they make I've heard that
they've made upward of eight billion
dollars since 2007.
yeah it's pretty incredible the
membership dues that they collect are
now a tiny fraction just a little over
10 percent of the revenue they have on
an annual basis the principal business
that they're in is not representing
seniors it's monetizing seniors it's
selling branded products to seniors and
in particular their Cash Cow are the
health insurance products the Medicare
Part D plans the Medicare Advantage
plans but especially the Medigap
supplemental insurance plans that they
sell
exclusively United Health Products and
they've got an exclusive deal with the
United States listen I'm fine with this
critique but where is the panel
criticizing the NRA which also claims to
be just a group who helps gun owners
where's the critique of the NRA because
they bring in 300 million dollars a year
and are part of all sorts of special
interest groups and and you know it's
it's very it's very uh um cherry-picked
Williams and pulls it out and takes it
for their General operating purposes and
uh
I think that's what you call a junk fee
I mean it's uh it seems to be the only
junk fee that the Democrats and the
president like though because so much of
that money gets recycled into liberal
advocacy and Democratic politics and so
you have is sort of the Confluence of a
notional non-profit but that's running
billions of dollars through it from a
corporate partnership oh like the NRA
always seems to benefit one political
party let's Steve let's just like the
NRA have one of the biggest players in
Washington by total number of members
and what we've just heard about their
budget how does that come in your
opinion how does that compromise them as
someone who's supposed to be this sort
of fair dealer in Washington
representing America's seniors what does
that do to them well look I I call AARP
American Association of ripping off
taxpayers right and I hope and one of
the reasons I wanted to be here in
common you folks because we have so
clever senior citizens in the this room
we have a lot of young people can we all
make a pact we're never going to join
the AARP there's no way are we going to
join the ARP I just turned 63. so I'm
getting all these mailers every month
join up for the ARP most of the mailers
he gets are about how not to have your
tie be way too long okay let's step away
from this a little bit and look at a
couple of other things uh let's just
check where we are here in the agenda
coming up next will be 87
000 pink slips about
I don't know I guess the IRS then it
will be Matt schlapp and Chris ready
where it will start to get interesting
then we'll speak to Mike pump here from
Mike Pompeo Eric Schmidt and then
Candace Owens will close out tonight
which I am sure
is just going to be
riveting and electric and they are you
know probably a couple hours behind
Crimson watch Sesame Super Chat
beautiful to see CPAC trash return one
of the best coupon codes ever created
and began my humble Journey as a pacman
subscriber f c pack absolutely
is that George Costanza from Seinfeld
which oh this guy here yeah yes it is
absolutely it is big thank you to Zach
Langford
Matt Stone and Ryan Bela for signing up
on my website putting us at 63 new
members for the day this feed continues
to be glitchy so we will stay over here
let me see what oh I if you'll allow me
to just briefly step away Dave Rubin who
by the way I didn't think Reuben was
still doing his YouTube channel or like
doing anything because I haven't come
across any of Dave rubin's content for a
couple years now
um Dave Rubin defended Scott Adams
racist rant
um Scott Adams of course the Dilbert guy
who I used to like and you know he's
been on the show and he's since blocked
me and it's all crazy here is Dave
rubin's take on Scott Adams I have not
heard this before Richard it says what
are your thoughts on the Scott Adams
controversy was he wrong so if you have
not heard about this there's a major
controversy involving Scott Adams first
off I like Scott Adams I consider him a
friend he is a good man and uh that let
me just put that there period he's like
I'm completely biased and basically just
address my thoughts based on who I'm
friends with and like not losing friends
so understanding that I am a completely
un uh unfair Arbiter of what Scott Adams
said let me now deliver my view
by the way we got him involved in locals
he loved it so much immediately very
early on he was like hey I'd love to I'd
love to invest can I can I throw some
money into this thing because I really
believe in it and he's oh so he's an
investor we're now
we're now going to hear
we're we're now going to hear an
analysis of whether Scott Adams racist
rant was racist
from a guy who was paid by Scott Adams
genius absolute genius he put his money
where his mouth is and he's just a good
man yeah the controversy basically is
this there was a video going viral
where we're produced by a leftist
organization with a series of black
people basically in essence saying they
don't like white people and here's why
and it was promoted by this Lefty
organization okay and Scott watched it
um and and then he also saw this there
was this other poll uh that basically uh
50 of black Americans think it's wrong
to be white I it's it's Dave Rubin
really has a gift for clearly explaining
premises as you can tell I don't know
how accurate the poll is you know my
feelings about polls in general but he
watched this video and then that poll
and then what he commented on on his
live stream he does this live stream on
locals all the time well he does
livestream all over the place but now
he's being canceled left and right so I
think it'll probably be exclusive on
locals in essence what he said was my
advice to white people would be not to
go to areas where there are a bunch of
people who hate you going off the
information he had just heard
he did not say anything racist he did
not say I don't like black people he
didn't say you shouldn't like black
people or anything like that he was
taking a certain set of information that
he had heard and then secretary said he
considers black people a hate group and
what what is the real what is the
reality of this if these people want
special laws for One race and another
loss for another race we used to call
that racist right
um you know I'm imagine let's say uh 50
of Germans said that uh you know you
shouldn't like Jews you think there
would be a problem there so so again
putting aside the percentages on this
and everything else all he said was my
advice to you would be well you wouldn't
want to move into a neighborhood like
that anyway a bunch of newspapers
canceled Dilbert he got a his book with
penguins this isn't this isn't the Crux
of what Scott Adams said obviously which
is my publisher the publisher I've used
in the past I suspect I will not be
using them again uh he uh got his next
book canceled by them and a whole bunch
of other stuff but he wisely is on
Rumble and locals anyway I think he's a
good dude he he's he's inflammatory and
he's intentionally inflammatory and he
likes poking the bear
um that's part of what he does but he he
is not a racist
okay anyway so Dave Rubin uh is fine
with what Scott Adams uh said
very exciting
super chats are coming in Brett Cohen
says David why is it now both parties
obfuscate and conflate data with ease in
the public lap setup in ignorance for
the most simplistic incitement well
listen
um one of the things I don't hide the
fact that I'm on the left
I never hide that on this program
but one of the things I make every
effort not to do is not to play partisan
games with Statistics when we talk about
debt and deficit gas prices inflation
unemployment whatever I don't play these
games where I talk about it one way
depending on who's President and another
way depending on who's President and I
can't speak for others but that's what I
try to do Brett
um Discman says David sir always a
pleasure to watch your YouTube huge
streams bigger than China and I know
streams believe me I've streamed more
than anyone's ever seen before but they
don't want to talk about that that's
right the fake news media won't tell you
about streams
narrator says when liberals don't keep
the same energy on calling Candace Owens
blackfaced that they would if a
conservative called Obama black-faced
Obama it's a reminder that for some
liberals anti-racism is just another
tokenization of us
I read something that said blackfaced
not a term that I use pejoratively or
tongue-in-cheek or whatever so I don't
know that must be meant for the person
who said that I don't know
Sager says Sir with tears in my eyes I'm
asking you do you have plans to visit
Australia if you do I strongly suggest
you stay in Melbourne it is the coffee
capital of the world and Australia's
cultural capital I would love to go to
Australia soon and I have to say as
interested as I am in going to Australia
I'm really interested in going to New
Zealand uh not not like competing or
comparing or anything like that but two
places I would very much like to visit I
want to say a big thank you to Keo
Bradley
as well as Teresa West who signed up
with our great coupon code CPAC trash we
have a goal of a hundred website members
and twitch subscribers if you have
Amazon Prime you get a free twitch Prime
subscription you can use it right now if
you're watching on Twitch it'll push us
closer we'll open phone lines if we get
to 100 as we wait for the speeches to
continue let's see if I can squeeze in
like one more voicemail here
um as we wait for more interesting
speeches and the entire thing
uh let's see what I've got here
a lot of very very mediocre stuff but
let's listen to this one
hey David I just had a question about
your your new Spanish-speaking Channel
um you recently referenced in one of
your live streams that you are doing the
overdubs because you don't have enough
hours in the day to do to record your
show in English and then re-record in
Spanish which is totally understandable
but I was wondering since you're doing
the
um since you're doing the overdubbing
and paying presumably for the
overdubbing for this week and that is
not cheap by the way that is not cheap
Channel I was wondering if you've
considered doing maybe like once a week
or something doing a show in Spanish and
having it overdubbed into English oh you
know I I just I really don't have time
for anything extra I really don't and I
there we have so many ideas come in and
I I get it there's all we I could always
be doing more
but I just really can't I've got to set
the limit somewhere and one of the
things I've been working on is setting
those limits and not taking on
um more I mean listen I should also like
improve my French a little and maybe do
it in French too I don't know I don't
know Occam's taser and Ryan 83 have just
re-up twitch Prime subscriptions pushing
us towards 67 as Stephen Moore continues
to rant and Rave let's listen to a
couple of other
voicemails as we start to get into the
thick and Meaty part of today's CPAC day
let's see what else I have as far as
voicemails go the voicemails have been
very very weak lately
people are asking for something from
Whitney let me see if I can find
something from her
uh
it is just it is really really tough
right now on the from the standpoint of
voicemails
uh
uh let's see if we can find something
that might titillate to some degree a
lot of problem callers that will call 10
times in a row they mostly just get Auto
deleted it's just like we just can't
even keep up with that you know
we're super super busy
uh I'm not seeing anything from uh
Whitney lately oh hold on here's
something from Whitney let's say
so I have
um an aunt
um she's like uh helping me with my
finances and stuff like that nice and
she's not like really brilliant
um yeah she's been able to just kind of
like keep her head like a little bit of
over water but she also has a husband so
it's like I have to put that into
context with me not really having a
husband right
um I have like a a life partner who sort
of helps me with some things that's nice
um
but um anyways
uh she's like telling me about how when
she talks to lawyers like oh sure she
knows like a little bit of lawyer Jorgen
Jordan you know I was just thinking to
myself like these standards that these
women hold to us meanwhile they have
husbands who like you know speak for
extremely a lot I've noticed that like
you know when a man with a deep voice
has something like the same way that I
do he gets it
um like I don't know like if something's
wrong in the apartment or something like
that then I would have to like listen A
lot's going on over at Whitney's place
it's sort of beyond the scope of this
show to really deal with that but I do
think it's uh very interesting what's
going on over there Mephisto has just
subscribed via twitch Prime and his new
member number 68 I very much appreciate
that let's listen a little more to
ranting and raving about the AARP as we
are about to get into sort of the Crux
of today's
speeches I would love to see Whitney
speaking at CPAC for sure just they
don't tell you what they cost and then
you get the bill and you pass it on the
insurance company so why not have them
require these these doctors and
hospitals to post the price so when we
know what we're paying for right I mean
it's like going into a store and saying
oh I love that dress and I'm going to
buy it and you don't know how it costs
and you know it's just so infuriating to
me the way government screws everything
up I know this is a little bit off topic
but you know there was a headline today
in the newspaper that Global the entire
panel's off topic greenhouse gas
emissions were the highest they've ever
been in history we've spent a hundred
billion dollars for the last 20 years
trying to reduce carbon emissions and
they're higher now than ever before and
why is that because of course China and
we're so all of these bills that the
Democrats spend more and more money on
and now that's another 500 billion
Energy Progress I say hell no not one
more penny for that crap I think uh
supposedly Milton Friedman once said if
you put the government in charge of the
Sahara you'd have a shortage of sand no
that's something like that it's this you
know Milton Friedman you said so you
notice this folks every time we have a
government program that's not working
what do the Democrats say you guys we
have to spend more money have you
noticed that they always were working
they shut down half these damn agencies
they are now working and balance the
budget and return the money to the
taxpayers here's my uh Steve Moore on
fire we see him on Fox fires today let
me just use this last minute we have to
answer your question I would urge
Republicans to be much Bolder than
whatever they think the boldest thing
they can get on how fast yes we've got
for the last time someone just said that
this guy's in his 30s that kid that
can't possibly be true
record low inpatient utilization people
were scared to go to the hospital they
were scared to go to doctors we had
people dying of heart attacks and
strokes because of lies from public
health officials who made them think
there was no room for them and then we
bailed out these hospitals over and over
and over again with our health care
money and so I think we need to take on
the hospitals we need to take on the
insurance companies we need to take on
the government bureaucrats we need to
say we're going to have a functioning
system where you control your own health
care dollars and there's real
competition not one Health System that
dominates everything in town because we
made the bureaucracy so bad that you
can't run an independent Physicians
practice anymore because you can't deal
with all of the government so I think
blow up as much of it as you can put
people in charge of their own health
care and get Physicians back in charge
of running their own practices not one
of the interesting things about CPAC if
I may is that you know it really is a
lay person crowd and what I mean by that
is like anybody can go to CPAC it's not
it's not an event for activists it's not
an event for elected officials or any of
that stuff and they don't really have
any prescriptions for lack of a better
term
for what people should even be doing to
try to like achieve these goals or like
blow up this system blow up that system
and then these marxists and then these
school boards and all these different
things now thank goodness that they're
not giving anybody anything actionable
to do although they can still kind of
radicalize people into just being like
well maybe I should do something violent
and that that's certainly an issue but
it's very interesting because it's a
strange thing where they talk like the
people in the audience do anything other
than just sit in home a sit at home and
watch Fox News
um it's a very interesting sort of thing
no no Solutions are proposed of course
thanks to Dante 721 for the twitch Prime
subscription you are number 69 today if
we get to a hundred and we're getting
close we will open phone lines let's
look at what is next on the agenda next
on the agenda is 87
000 pink slips I presume that that would
be about the IRS
um Crimson watch says via Super Chat
seems like the stage design has gone
back to a more traditional Americana
theme
uh save the odle runes and burning cross
motifs for another year yeah they seem
to have backed off of that at least a
little bit big thank you to Christopher
Stewart who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code CPAC trash
CPAC trash is today's coupon code let's
see if we can squeeze in a couple more
voicemails
uh
let's see what we've got here
I noticed that Hollywood during the
Holocaust
um joint Germany which is like
um
uh kind of like Russia nope we're
getting the hell away from that let's
see what else I have here
uh
hmm
hey David just a really important issue
um I listened to all my podcasts at one
and high speed
it's just something else
okay
I don't know what the hell that was that
was very very weird
uh I re I wish I had like some
voicemails to play for you that made
even a semblance an iota of sense
but there really isn't all right let's
see let's see what this what's going on
here I think this is the last sort of
like trash panel before they get to like
the real content
[Applause]
Chris Ruddy who runs let me just refresh
real quick because the audience okay
this is the guy who privately messages
me and tells me he likes the David
Pacman show he's the CEO of Newsmax uh
stations and you have about 25 million
viewers according to according to
Nielsen but people may remember Newsmax
started as a website in 1998 right I had
been a journalist covering the clintons
nationally at the New York Post imagine
if they just put the David Pacman show
on Newsmax like totally out of context
there's just like this one hour of
progressive commentary yes in the 90s so
I started Newsmax and we had tremendous
growth over the years and then about
2014 to 16 we decided to launch a cable
and streaming news channel called
Newsmax and I'm glad to report we're the
fourth highest rated cable news channel
in the United States now
Now understand how deceptive that is
it's like there's MSNBC Fox and CNN
and then it's like there's Newsmax it
what he's saying is one of those things
that's technically true but quite
deceptive
they don't watch Fox or CNN anymore they
can't they don't get it and they're on
these devices like Samsung and Pluto and
Zumo so we're for the moment on both
eventually we're going to have two
channels Newsmax one and Newsmax two but
it's been a very exciting and it's
really hey you know what would be funny
actually
I should start a campaign for my
audience to contact Newsmax
and just ask them to carry the David
Pacman show not with any insults or like
just completely out of context and it
would probably get back to ready and he
would probably just be kind of confused
like it wouldn't even really it would
just be just to confuse him first being
made in this area well I hope so
um you know it was a little bit of shock
to us because we've been around for over
five years now we're on every major
cable system last year we were renewed
with hundreds of Cable Systems including
dish and Verizon and then DirecTV we
could not come to agreement They removed
us on January 24th we went dark on 13
million homes they're a huge market
share player now as you know at T owns a
significant portion of DirecTV and they
had removed the one America channel last
year
popular conservative Channel didn't have
the ratings we had but very popular
and our view was that it was censorship
now they say that it wasn't that they
want more conservative voices they've
added a conservative commentary Channel
when we heard that we said great that's
good have more voices
the nice thing is about two weeks ago
they announced that they would consider
bringing Newsmax back on and they are
working I think to to that end we're
hopeful that we can come to some
agreement it's not for sure but I think
both parties would like to do it and I
think it would be a great Testament to
them and the diversity of voices that
they're having that's right there's a
lot
cleaning channels on DirecTV don't you
think DirecTV should reinstate news max
yeah I mean
CPAC got involved in this fight as well
and sending a letter to ATT and DirecTV
and the board basically saying look
don't Silas silent conservatives we need
more diversity in terms of our content
the Liberals on the left basically own
everything in the media world and if you
look at all not just DirecTV but most
Cable Systems they're by any number at
least a dozen two dozen liberal news and
information channels even the comedy
channel is liberal news for Millennials
that's kids believe that there's news
when they tune in
um and now people who watch Newsmax
think that's news that that but so what
sucks in my mind has been good but we
can't rely why should the left have so
many news choices but conservatives only
have one yeah and fox let's admit it is
changing and it's good to have more
voices and I think Newsmax plays a very
critical role in offering those I think
options this is what American consumers
deserve when we talk about censorship
involving conservatives how serious do
you think it is especially when you're
looking at the big Tech world and in
essence where many conservatives feel
like their voices are not being heard we
are in a like one minute to midnight
situation this country where voices and
conservative voices are being closed
down yeah there's almost no conservative
Media Left guys I know you wouldn't know
it from everything you see but it's
about to be obliterated there won't be
anything left
so powerful because of a law Congress
passed in 96 when the internet was very
small the communications decency act and
it had a rule called section 230. and
basically it gives social media and
these big companies like Google the
ability to Mint money because those
companies are excluded from lawsuits
you're not excluded from lawsuits I'm
not none of you are but imagine you had
this is so deceptive now you can we
reasonable people can disagree about
section 230. it's not that Google can't
be sued all section 230 relates to is if
I post a video on YouTube making violent
threats for example
YouTube can't be sued because of what I
said even though I uploaded it to their
platform that's all that means if
someone posts a defamatory tweet you
can't sue Twitter for defamation you can
go after the person who put up the tweet
you can say that should be the case or
it shouldn't be the case but to pretend
that the companies are immune from
lawsuits it it relates to a very narrow
aspect of it and it's extraordinarily
deceptive what he said asks are
effective in combating covet
uh the scientific evidence actually
supports his view that there's limited
limited effectiveness
YouTube banned us for seven days and
they said they would permanently ban us
if we ever did one more mistake like
that he's a medical doctor he's a U.S
senator and he had a opinion that had
some scientist who's he talking about
Rand Paul
they're supposed to be a neutral
platform not a publisher they act like a
publisher they should be treated like a
publisher 230 should be eliminated I
hope the Supreme Court
there's no
Roofing to 230 it can't be reformed
because they will always find an excuse
to break the rules with it they created
a special class of speech that never
existed it's not constitutional I hope
the high court in these recent cases
throws it out well let me ask you this
there's something called the global
disinformation index and News Guard
that I've learned about that they're
supposedly independent and neutral last
time I checked they seemed incredibly
liberal and I really want Chris to
explain what they are because it's scary
and I really think conservatives should
be concerned a lot of the starts out of
the fact checking movement all of these
liberal groups started creating fact
Checkers and all the conservative facts
are wrong and all the liberal facts are
right so that's kind of interesting so
we've seen that and so then they decided
you know what why don't we create these
independent monitoring agencies will
rate sites all the liberal sites like
CNN New York Times get great scores no
matter what they do think about what CNN
did all the problems and the scandals
the cuomos the Russian collusion and
they're among the most highest rated by
newsguard right you get the real truth
on Newsmax well he's been in the media
business long-time Democratic donor we
find out a number of the people work
their former Democratic operatives their
rating conservative sites like new
Newsmax and Washington Times prageru We
All Get Low ratings okay that's their
opinion
but these big ad agencies giant agencies
are now using them to block
conservatives from getting advertising
Revenue a lot of whining going on here
guys this entire thing is whining the
defense department we're funding these
groups you are funding these liberal
rating groups and what they're trying to
do is demonetize conservative media and
it's a threat to our constitutional
freedoms and in fact we have a story on
Newsmax today that Jimmy Patronus the
head of the CFO hell of a story saying
you can't use ESG in the State of
Florida to close down conservative media
well it looks like Congress should look
into this as well and quite frankly
schlatt we might think about a media
monitoring rating system at CPAC I'm
kind of liking this idea but let me ask
you Chris uh you know obviously the
left-wing media they are salivating over
this Dominion voting system a lawsuit
against Fox and also talking about
salivating it's like maybe there will be
some accountability it's a sensitive
subject right we're being sued for 1.6
billion dollars I don't know where they
came up with that number
um and fox is being sued for that amount
um and if you look at the the facts of
the case even all of these salacious
emails and texts that came out of the
Fox suit you may have heard about it
what it showed was that fox was a news
organization a big news organization
where on a controversial news subject
there were disagreements among the staff
about that's not what it showed that's
not what it showed what it showed is
that despite claiming to be news they
put stuff out for its entertainment
value not for its newsworthiness because
they knew they were putting out lies I
was supposed to have an opinion even if
it might have been different from his so
actually you know I know a lot of people
like to criticize Fox these days but I
think that what these texts showed to me
was there was a dynamic in there
Fox can show you just like Newsmax that
so what we're being sued for is that we
reported what president Trump Rudy
Giuliani and the campaign officials were
alleging about that election nope that's
not true it's that they continued to
welcome uh and completely uncritically
air the claims of people like Sydney
Powell and others that were obviously
untrue including defense allegedly
defamatory claims about Dominion's
involvement that is not just saying
Trump thinks he won
and why when they did the Russian
collusion story where they made
countless allegations against President
Trump nobody and they were all found to
be false nobody said CNN and MSNBC in
fact there's been no accountability for
what they did
um I think our statement of facts in
this case are very strong I think Fox's
statement of account if we were not in a
Delaware Court
small state liberal Democratic State the
Biden families close with everybody
there
um oh that is genius you know there are
so many reasons why so many corporations
are either based in Delaware or
contracts agree to be a subject to
arbitration in Delaware that have
nothing to do with Biden and it just so
happens Biden's from Delaware and so he
slips that in Biden being from Delaware
has nothing to do with the entire
Delaware Corporate industrial complex
that exists covering the election uh
it's always a fun we always call it the
Super Bowl for us and it's already
started and Donald Trump adds a
tremendous amount of electricity I think
he's coming here on Saturday so it's
going to be very exciting
but you know what I'm
Donald Trump since 1999 and I see him
all the time because I live down in
Florida not far from him I'm a member of
his club and I'm a great friend of his
even though we don't agree on everything
and I certainly don't agree on every
approach he takes to everything but I do
respect his tenacity and all right
anyway I'm aware that the audio is off
we just are having an issue with some of
the other streams let's see if this
one's better next year it is expect
Newsmax to cover the presidential
election well we're really excited about
covering the election uh it's always a
fun we always call it the Super Bowl for
us and it's already started and Donald
Trump adds a tremendous so we already
this one's on a little bit of a delay
all right so um this we're starting to
get into the marginally more interesting
stuff which is fine
um thanks to Lisa's weather boxer and
mitter Binion for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 73. also big
thank you to Rebecca Hayes as well as
Juan the troll man each gifting a
subscription putting us at 75 folks we
are three quarters of the way there the
goal is 100 and we will open phone lines
when we get there coming up next here is
uh well so I guess so this seems to be
that instead of match slap they replaced
him with his wife Mercedes schlapp for
the Chris ready interview so it looks
like Mom Mike Pompeo will be next then
Eric Schmidt and then Candace Owens
maybe they're running about 25 to 30
minutes behind is the sense that I get
but we're getting into the sort of like
Prime events today and uh you know Prime
is certainly in the eye of the beholder
Brian Hovey just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 76. Trump said they backed Jeb
Bush Ruby on Kasich to try to stop him
they they now have other candidates
they're looking at apparently and that's
their prerogative but I personally
believe that the best for the country is
for the voters to have both sides and
then you need to make an informed
decision rather than me sort of picking
a candidate that I like and I think the
network if you look at Newsmax we get
accused of all sorts of things I think
we're one of the most balanced networks
out there because we're always trying to
get like the other side what on Earth
Bill Buckley used to say this it's an
overtly right-wing conspiracy Network
as admiring Bill Buckley he said
conservatives don't need to own the
media all we need is a fair Shake where
you get both sides because 80 percent of
the time the Public's going to side with
us obviously that's completely untrue we
know that the public has abandoned the
right on abortion on gay marriage on
taxes on climate on all these different
issues a few Mercedes thank you Matt
absolutely and I just want to give one
shout out Ted Cruz has been tremendous
supporter of Newsmax we appreciate it
Jim Comer on the house side that's right
thank you thank you all
seeming like a pretty damn weak crowd I
have to tell you
[Music]
thank you
is it just me or is CPAC particularly
pathetic this time around
I don't know it's something something
weird is going on blueberry babe has
resubscribed and gifted two
subscriptions on Twitch which I very
much appreciate very very much
appreciate uh let's see if I have
anything else voicemail wise
um
let me see what I have
I really don't have good voicemails to
play for you I I just I'm sorry oh
they're already going to the next thing
let's see
thank you well well this is the most
exciting part of the day we get to do
taxes and economics at the same time oh
right right you know I gotta like set
the record straight though and by the
way I'm Kevin Hassett this is Jason
Smith in case you didn't know uh
chairman of the Ways and Means Committee
this could be the biggest dud of the day
right now I would say as much as Kevin
McCarthy because uh you've got so many
fights to fight but I want to set the
record straight to start with that a lot
of people say that Joe Biden's policies
are not going to create any jobs
but it's not true is it Economist I
could tell you that he has an 80 billion
dollar bill that gives creates 87 000
jobs for the IRS
um and and if you look at the details
all right I'll take this opportunity to
take a five while we watch this then
we'll be back and carry through to the
end and Q including of course the
world's famous Candace Owens information
about you from wherever from your
Facebook page wherever combining it with
your tax status so that they can go
around and audit you know every American
it's big brother odd steroids well I've
noticed Jason that you disagree with
this policy and that you've been trying
to stand up to it I wonder if you could
talk about that a little bit I would say
I more than disagree with this policy
um it's great to it's great to be with a
bunch of conservatives right
you have definitely raised the IQ level
in Washington DC by just being here so
um we are grateful that you're here
um
000 IRS employees agents whatever you
want to call it
Joe Biden has been pushing this policy
since his very first president's budget
his very first president's budget he
highlighted that he wanted 80 billion
dollars of new money
to hire 87 000 IRS employees but he also
put in there that he wanted to do what I
refer to as the bank snooping bill
and that is if there's a an amount of
ten thousand or more inflow or outflow
of your bank account
it's going to be reported to the IRS
it's all about government command and
control over your lives is what this
Administration what the Democrat party's
trying to do to just be completely
honest and so the Ways and Means
Committee has not been a committee known
for oversight but the very first bill
that we did from our committee was to
eliminate that 80 billion dollars that
was the first bill we did in the entire
House of Representatives
but we got to keep up the drum beat
because
the Ways and Means Committee has
jurisdiction over the IRS
and at my first week as chairman I set
up this whistleblower hotline
that any employee of the IRS could
contact us and let us know if there's
something they think we should be
looking into that may not just be right
that they don't feel comfortable to tell
the folks at the top
we've been getting some good stuff all
right let's just tell you
and so stay tuned because our committee
we're going to be very aggressive on
oversight and we're going to expose what
this Administration is trying to do in
targeting rural Americans and that is
not going to be stood for in this
Congress we are going to be pushing back
tooth and now I can tell you that you
know uh thank you so much for that
and uh we were talking backstage that
when Hillary Clinton uh first went into
the White House as first lady one of the
things she did is she asked the IRS to
give her the tax returns of the
Clinton's enemies this is public
and she got them
and more recently uh your colleagues
decided to release the tax return for a
former president uh
uh the IRS has been hacked over and over
so that probably most people in this
room you know the Russians of the
Chinese have their tax data and
propublica has been writing articles
about the tax returns of private
citizens what are you doing to stop that
we have already started the
investigation over 19 months ago there
was a leak of almost a thousand
taxpayers information
by propublica it came from somewhere and
still we've heard crickets from the IRS
of how did this leak happen it just
happened to be the same time within the
same week this Administration was trying
to push tax increases on those same
thousand people that
their tax returns released but it's not
just that
there was a hundred and twelve hundred
and thirteen thousand
taxpayers retirement information that
was posted on a website by the IRS
and then they figured out they did it
wrong after eight months and took it
down
and was supposed to rework it so there
wasn't confidential information and they
posted the same thing again twice
if you have that kind of disrespect for
people's private tax information and
retirement information there's a problem
at the IRS and we've got to figure that
out that's right and one of the problems
that you could actually if you go to the
IRS website and look at it one of the
problems is that because they're trying
to rake in as much cash as they can from
everybody they share information with
foreign governments and so in 2021 the
IRS shared the tax information of
Americans with foreign governments or
foreign or other entities in the
government 27 billion times
27 billion times and so this is a
problem that you know thank goodness
that you're on the case but another
thing that you've done recently that
I've noticed that really fills my heart
with joy is that there was an article uh
in Politico if I remember correctly that
said that
um that when you came in and you
announced that you're going to put the
American people and blue-collar workers
first that it sent all the lobbyists in
Washington into a tizzy I'm quoting and
so I think that you should put that on
your Tombstone I hope it's a long ways
off but but I'm so proud of you for
putting like an industry on a tizzy yeah
but but but how did you put them on a
Disney and what does it mean that
they're in it you know it's crazy that
it's news that if a member of Congress
or a chairman of a committee is going to
prioritize the working class small
businesses and Farmers as their top
priorities when they're developing
policies when it comes to tax trade and
health care
why does that make these lobbyists and a
tizzy that tells you exactly how broken
Washington DC is I mean it just it that
that is how broken it is and the place
that I represent is God's country I I
know we all live in God's country but
Southeast Missouri Cape Girardeau home
of Rush Limbaugh you might have all
heard of him so is this the most
electric panel tonight or what I had to
have him from our great area and I was
raised the same way he was you know
um from a working class background and
and that's who I represent and we need
to make sure our policy is up here
are reflected to deliver for
working-class families so so the one
thing I want to say though is that I
live in DC and I consider DC God's
country too we do see residents are not
I think we might disagree I'm just
saying BDC residents this is really
really really bad so I think they kind
of flip-flopped a couple of these panels
so I believe that next would be Pompeo
who's that's going to be like 40 to 45
minutes behind then it's Eric Schmidt
and then Candace Owens so maybe they'll
end at like 6 45 or something like that
I don't know I mean there it's they're
falling further and further behind and
not because they have something really
interesting or special going on Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer did a very good
job during the two years that they were
one party control of doing everything
wrong that's exactly what they were
doing every policy that they made was
the wrong policy for our country and
those two years they added more than 10
trillion dollars of new spending that's
not even counting really the spending to
fund government and keep the lights on
this was just on top of it 10 trillion
and when you think about it from that
perspective and what did you get for it
very muted crowd reaction to that as you
can tell uh thanks to Jeremy Ranch and
AJ the greater for the twitch Prime
subscriptions folks we are within
Striking Distance of 100. uh oh what's
on yeah I did want to talk a little bit
about the schedule tomorrow uh so we can
figure out when the stream should be
there is some interesting stuff in the
morning
so in the morning they've got Sebastian
Gorka which should be kind of
interesting
Marjorie Taylor green is speaking at 10
A.M Eastern
Matt gates at 10 30 Sean Spicer at 10
40.
and then gilfoyle at 11 35 Don Jr at 11
45 like that's all pretty wacky
interesting stuff I just don't know if I
can do the morning I have to see what's
going on with my schedule
then later in the afternoon it gets
crazy also you've got Nikki Haley Lara
Trump Pompeo again I guess I don't know
it's kind of weird I don't know he's
going to be back
um and then what else do we have Wayne
LaPierre Francis Suarez
Vivek ramaswamy
Steve Bannon Nigel farage you know I
think I may end up having to do like
basically Bannon and farage but then we
can look at clips from earlier I just
because it's all everything's all spread
out throughout the day
um so we'll we'll see we'll see uh we'll
see how tomorrow goes essentially
um and then kind of go from there
a couple other voicemails I'm I'm really
trying here to play voicemails for
people
but
they're they're just
I've got 730 voicemails I haven't
listened to
and they're seeming very
very mediocre
David Parkman my name is Asa Asa
I just want to respond to your recession
comment and anybody with any political
experience forget about financial uh
opinions because they really don't yeah
they're not gonna get about it but I'm
gonna get it right right now I guarantee
you six months before the presidential
election you can guarantee it
a big money people well
start pulling their money out just like
when when uh Biden announced he had two
hundred thousand more jobs last month
Elon Musk lays lays off 200 000 people
just to show you the power of the money
side and you can I guarantee you because
at one level or another
that's when you're going to see it
because uh yeah well listen Elon musk's
Tesla has 120 000 employees so how he
would lay off 200 000 employees is a
mathematical quandary SP Bennis says via
super chat if it comes down to a bitter
Trump versus the Santa's Showdown should
DeSantis emphasize Trump's role in the
Insurrection would it gain or lose on
the fence Republican voters I think
that's very risky for DeSantis I'd be
curious to see what people in the crowd
say but um I think that that would be
very very risky for DeSantis to do you
really don't know how these lunatics are
going to react
it's called
in the heart
like the best Solutions are not in
Washington the best solution amongst the
entire American public and so that is
the policies we're developing to deliver
for working-class family small
businesses and farmers and and that is
exactly what will will make our country
even stronger we are the the backbone of
the economy is the hard-working everyday
American and so the policies that we're
going to do in tax policy is going to be
crafted from going
to Petersburg to Oklahoma City and then
other places
and they will be policies that I know
that will help bring back our strategic
Supply chains we should not be dependent
on China
for our Pharmaceuticals or for our food
security or for our energy security
critical connection and we need to use
tax and trade policies to make sure that
if we cannot produce those items in our
country it needs to be in countries that
are our friends even like the host dude
is bored with this nonsense it's it's
almost sad how pathetic this CPAC is
almost almost
Badger says we have some lunatics over
the pond please cover farage greetings
from the UK yeah I'm going to the UK in
a few weeks I mean actually I haven't
been for a while I'm uh I'm excited to
be back
let's see what else we've got
uh
a lot a lot of uh
see if I can find an interesting
voicemail for folks here
let's see
hey dude it's James I uh I'm calling
about your tweet from uh a couple weeks
ago about how you uh are receiving
different messages
saying stop pushing Judaism onto people
first of all I have no reason to believe
that you're doing that
but then you went on to say
uh
some of the effect is there's no
prosthetizing allowed in Judaism
it's not there's no proselytizing
allowed there's just no proselytizing in
Judaism
but I know a lot of Jewish people who
have one parent who couldn't marry who
have one parent that was Jewish yeah and
they couldn't marry the non-jewish
parent unless the non-jewish parent
converted Judaism okay so wouldn't that
be a form of hospitalization no and in
fact if you go to a rabbi and if you say
I want to convert you will very quickly
see based on the rabbi's reaction how it
is not proselytizing uh
all right
um let's see what else we've got here
hey Dave if we ever thought if we ever
thought Kirsten Cinema was ever full of
crap pretending to be a Democrat the
second that the Democrats have power and
her one vote has no more power she opts
to be a an independent immediately as
soon as they lose she's an individual
she has no more power she's independent
to give herself power again it's so fake
and obvious This Woman's disgusting
right is it Joe manchin gonna do the
same thing Dave
why did she do this explained Shalom all
right well I did we we've talked about
that extensively we've talked about that
extensively
Mr Pac-Man sir I think you're making a
big I think you're making a big mistake
when it comes to trying to get those
three million people to subscribe
because you forget the love that might
be hate Watchers so you need to find a
way to get the hate Watchers to also
subscribe no no no I don't need so what
this caller is referring to is
we have uh what's the number let's see
what the number is here hold on this is
the number of YouTube subscribers that
we have right now okay and one of the
statistical realities is that every
month somewhere between two and four
million different people
who are not subscribed watch my Clips
okay so when I say hey it would be great
if a bunch of those people did subscribe
I'm aware that a lot of people are hate
watching like I'm completely aware of
that I'm talking about the ones that
aren't if you think if you figure even
if half the people are hate Watchers if
three million people who aren't
subscribed or watching every month
you've got a million and a half who
aren't hate Watchers okay if it's fifty
percent so that's who I'm talking to
forget about the hate Watchers forget
about the hate Watchers you don't need
them sir you just don't need them okay
let's see if we've got anything else
here of note oh what's next let's see
so I think now Mike Pompeo is next
we'll see very soon we'll see very very
soon
but it's uh I think the schedule is all
screw it really is
um
am I opening phone lines okay I'll say
it just once more if we get to a hundred
website members and twitch subscribers
we're at 81 okay we're at 81. if we get
to 100 I'll open phone lines you can use
the coupon code CPAC trash
for a discount okay let's see if I can
squeeze in like one more voicemail
hey pack boy just wanted to say you're
uh
available
Trump 2024 fight in prison 2024 and
yeah that's it
later
um
okay
let's see what else we've got
hey David it's Tommy I don't know how
relevant this is or not
um but I noticed you say with peace and
love a lot usually when asking us
listeners for things or whatnot well
usually when I'm kind of saying
something a little negative
it kind of reminds me of a Time Ringo
Starr
you do not send anything after whatever
date
kind of what reminded me of yeah that's
where I got it I got it from Ringo Starr
that's uh that's exactly right megwine
with a
22.22 super chat says hola senor David
hello David sir love the show sending
well wishes for you and the fam Avec I
think that means with tears in my eyes
keep up the good work thank you thank
you to Sterling Lana for gifting to
subscriptions via twitch Prime as we are
moments away moments away I think from
Mike pompeo's speech although we never
really know because the schedule is just
a mess it's backwards constantly and who
the hell knows what it is that is going
on uh let's see what else I've got here
as far as voicemails go
uh is there anything anything even
remotely interesting here
Tucker Carlson something or other
something about pillow
I don't know
hi David Doug from South Dakota I was
watching your uh clip about Tucker
Carlson and
mutilate mutilating children Etc
um yeah
why hasn't anybody pushed back against
the religious bigotry and used
circumcision as
an alternative talking point
circumcision is mutilating the genitalia
of children I don't think that that's
big with a lot of people so I think
that's why it's not being used all right
here is
who the hell is this
ladies and gentlemen it's great to be
with you here today
it's incredible to be with so many
Freedom loving Patriots from all across
the country
to come together for a very very
important Mission here at CPAC
to save America right
to fight for our values that we hold
dear
to dislodge the weaponized bureaucrats
from our lives to forget or to fight for
the Forgotten men and women of this
country
those hard-working Americans who play by
the rules and provide for their families
I see you
I hear you
and I understand your frustration and
your desire to pass along in America
that stands for freedom and opportunity
and I want you to know
that I'm with you in this fight and in
the United States Senate will fight for
you every single day oh wait a second is
this uh
I guess this is Eric Schmidt right so
they skipped Pompeo who knows what's
going on who I really have no idea
what's happening he has crushed
hard-working Americans
families are paying ten thousand dollars
more a year than they were just two
years ago because of this Reckless
Administration
Joe Biden has declared war on American
Energy
truck drivers are struggling to make
ends meet with the rising price of
diesel farmers and ranchers are at risk
of being denied loans because they have
too many diesel vehicles
massive corporations are pushing World
policies on us and in our kids
some of those same companies are holding
your retirement savings hostage
by incorporating ESG into their
Investments
to Virtue signal and appease climate
alarmists
the Biden Administration has weaponized
the FBI doj and other law enforcement
agencies against conservatives
every agency Under the Sun is now using
taxpayer-funded dollars to push divisive
Dei trainings
China
is rattling their saver preparing for
war
and Biden looks weak on the world stage
even letting a Chinese he really doesn't
any poll you look at actually shows
Biden being perceived as dramatically
stronger than Trump on the world stage
like not even close just not even
remotely close sorry and for Americans
across this country and I plan to
continue to push back on these woke
policies and Reckless spending and we
can and should be energy dominant again
all right
anyone there
and in my opinion ladies and gentlemen
we must recognize the biggest threat to
our freedoms is found in the
administrative State oh God
that is a three people clapping for that
term
but it is a grave threat to your
livelihood and to the very future of
self-government
unelected bureaucrats at all levels of
government have on this is bannon's
routine this is Steve bannon's routine
vocabulary everything
they're simply not accountable to you at
all
they want to tell you that you can't use
a gas stove to cook dinner for your
family
no one's telling you that regulate a
dried Creek bed or a drainage ditch on a
farm because of climate alarmism
they want to tell you can't have
firearms and defend yourself
they want to coordinate with social
media companies to censor your speech
because it doesn't fit the quote
narrative or the quote-unquote science
and that ladies and gentlemen should
scare the hell out of everybody in this
room
when I served as Missouri's attorney
general before I had this job
I never shied away from the fight
I filed a landmark lawsuit that I'm sure
some of you have heard of Missouri
versus Biden
no I haven't heard
and we also had that student loan dead
case before The Supreme Court that we're
going to win too by the way okay
we sued the byte Administration and the
FBI and HHS and other alphabet agencies
for colluding with social media Giants
whoever sensor freedom of speech on
their platforms
and what we found folks was unbelievable
it's still coming out we found that
there was direct blatant and Brazen
coordination between the federal
government and social media companies
on one occasion and it was the Trump
Administration trying to do the
coordination
and then pledged to censor speech on
covid-19 more stringently
government agencies had special portals
to quickly report posts they disagreed
with
prominent concern the Trump government
in their crosshairs
we deposed Anthony fauci
and demanded answers for the lives and
livelihoods that he ruined
[Applause]
and in the middle of that deposition I
kid you not a court reporter sneezed
what did Anthony faucially do he
demanded that she wear a mask
I'm not making this up this was just a
couple of months ago this is the
temperament by the way of the guy who
was in charge of all of this
who wanted power and control the guy who
proclaimed that he was the science
and when he was privately messaged in an
email we confronted him with by a
colleague
in early 2020 about whether she should
wear a mask on a plane or not he said
they were ineffective
but for the rest of us
we were required to wear them on planes
and our kids had to wear a mask in
schools all day long all across this
country and the takeaway from that
deposition was when fauci speaks big
Tech censored and this can never happen
again and not on my watch
[Applause]
let them forget what they did to us and
did to this great country
we also deposed FBI agent Elvis Chan
he told us that the FBI had monthly then
weekly meetings with social media
companies in the run-up to the 2020
election to warn them about Russian Hack
and leak operations and one of them
could be the hunter Biden laptop
they were priming the social media
companies to be ready to censor when the
story inevitably came out
the FBI had the laptop they knew it was
real inauthentic and yet they held these
meetings anyways
and the social media companies were all
too happy to carry out their orders that
is pure and utter insanity
further
if they can ban by the way the president
of the United States President Trump
imagine what they can do to you
and I have a quick question for the
folks in this audience that took a quick
poll how many people in this room have
been censored on social media
that's what I thought that's what I
thought
and by the way you you are exactly why I
fought so hard against censorship in
that lawsuit we conservatives the people
in this room
we have to be the Guardians of free
speech that is our mission that is our
call okay
if you control the flow of information
and limit speech you can control people
and that's exactly exactly what their
aim is power and control
that's what Mass mandates were all about
oh no first attorney general in the
country to file a lawsuit against OSHA's
unlawful vaccine mandate we took it to
the Supreme Court and we won
now they're clapping
I was proud to be one of the leaders in
pushing back against Cove and tyranny as
attorney general and my pledge to you is
to be one of the leading senators in
this country does anybody remember covid
tyranny interstate
[Music]
pull away from elective bureaucrats and
return it to We the People
you and you alone should have the
freedom to decide what's best for you
and your family not an unelected
bureaucrat who works for an agency
you've never heard of
and I'll be honest here
I'm the new guy in the Senate
I've been here for about two months
but I can tell you
that I'll work hard every single day to
claw power away from the government and
give it back to you or this is
everything that's wrong with the
American uh political space people like
this all over
weaponized
we do or we can stand up and we can
fight back for the freedoms that so many
have shed blood for I don't know about
you but I'm here and I am ready to help
lead that fight
all right
I want you to know I Won't Back Down
I wish he would back down I won't be
intimidated this is the fight let's win
it together thank you God bless you and
God bless the United States of America
thank you
and God bless
United States
so uh either we now have Mike Pompeo
followed by Candace Owens or Pompeo
isn't speaking after all and it'll be
just Candace Owens and then that'll be
it for today remains to be seen we are
getting uh oh Dan Norberg just signed up
on my website using the coupon code CPAC
trash it is Candace Owens next maybe
Pompeo is canceled let's see what
happens
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe she'll talk to us about breeding
for math
is anyone even clapping
uh first and foremost I just want to
thank you guys for having me back
thinking about it today and unbelievably
I've spoken at CPAC five times it seems
to have gone by so fast they've always
welcomed me Mercedes and Matt schlapp
and I'm just so grateful for that
opportunity and I really don't believe
that schlapp pummeled anybody's junk
it's changed since five years ago how
much all of our lives have changed since
five years ago how much the global
conversation has changed nobody could
have fathomed five years ago the covid
era nobody could have fathomed so much
Global governance taking place but I
think the biggest changes in my life
obviously have taken place on a personal
level I think about flying around the
world traveling with Charlie Kirk when I
first started and now I'm a married
mother of two children which is
the best part of life beginning for me
and and so much change is when you
become a parent you hear it all the time
and it's so correct and I think what
really changes is your understanding of
what matters in the world you know you
look at your children you look at your
family and you understand that this is
what really matters uh but in the same
vein you could say that you also
understand what doesn't matter what's
not important and then you also
understand what can't matter and I want
to talk about that for a little bit
because when I say what can't matter I'm
talking about matter as a word as a
substant existence of something what
things that cannot materialize I have
this thought all the time I'm so
preoccupied with thinking about things
that cannot materialize now that my
children are in this world because the
fight now seems so much more important
uh the battles now I'm we are deciding
upon the future for our children for my
children and I've never this is a hell
of a word salad that you first share
with you something that a colleague of
mine posted Matt wall she post this onto
his Twitter yesterday actually and I was
really struck by it because I've read
things like it from the past and I think
it really serves a reminder for everyone
in this room as to where we are today in
America this is the passage it was
written during the Civil War and this is
a letter to a loved one from a soldier
an infantryman oh my God Pennsylvania
he writes under the dark shade of a
towering Oak near the dunker Church lay
the lifeless form of a drummer boy
apparently not more than 17 years of age
flax and hair and eyes of blue and form
of delicate mold as I approached him I
stooped down and as I did so I perceived
a bloody Mark upon his forehead it
showed where the lead-in messenger of
death had produced the wound that caused
his death his lips were compressed his
eyes half open a bright smile played
upon his countenance by his side lay his
tenor drum never to be tapped again so
again to provide that context this was
written as just a letter to a loved one
from an 18 year old Soldier and why Matt
was struck by this passage and why I
have been similarly stricken by passages
like it reading these letters that just
soldiers 18 year old seven-year-old boys
were riding back home is how poetic and
how beautiful it is this is not written
by somebody with a formal education it's
written by an eight year old just saying
this is what I'm seeing on the
battlefields and yet it reads like a
haunting poetry what's being ignored is
that the culture of reading and literacy
in the first generations to come to the
United States what became the United
States
are dramatically different so it wasn't
formal education well but the the
culture at the time was so dramatically
different I mean it's just a meaningless
analogy in comparison this is not a
stunning example this is not a person
that was exceptional this was your
average 18 year old during the Civil War
so what's happened in American society
today we've given out so many degrees we
actually as a fact have have never given
out more degrees
and yet from an IQ perspective we have
never produced students that are this
dumb oh my God she's going she's like
all about Eugenics now by the way it
would make sense that the more people
there are in the country the more
degrees we would give out kind of makes
sense you have to ask yourself why or
how that is also the emergence at the
University level of what Thomas Soul
refers to as soft subjects right people
that are receiving all of these degrees
but getting them in bizarre subjects
like gender studies
what is that what do you do for four
years when you major in gender studies
what do you do when you graduate with a
degree in gender studies here I'll ask
you guys a question have you ever at any
moment in your entire life I want you to
think of every single moment in your
life have you ever in a time of trouble
or if you just had a basic question have
you ever said man I really need a gender
Studies major right now to sort through
this
[Applause]
I'm gonna guess the answers no I think
that there are some Fair criticisms of
gender studies I don't think this is
necessarily it and I don't know that the
context in which she's making it is good
faith
and yet these kids leave with their
degree and they are the most egotistical
conceited children that you've ever seen
certain that their degree means
something until they're smacked in the
face with the real world until they
realize that it's not just the people in
this room that laugh at gender studies
Majors it's it's everybody nobody needs
you right
and then that person that spent all of
that money and has all this debt and now
has met the real world and realizes that
they're not needed becomes a very angry
individual and let me tell you something
there is no person that is is more
dangerous than an angry person that
perceives their own intellect that
believes that the world owes them
something because how could these high
school kids that didn't go on to college
and just learned how to fix ACS how are
they making more money than me is what
this person thinks right I have a degree
in gender studies how is Joe from my
class back in middle school making more
money and running a business oh I don't
know because personally for me I live in
Tennessee let me tell you something
about Joe from middle school class if
he's running a business
when the AC goes out I will pay any
amount of money for that person to come
and fix an AC
because he has a real skill and real
skills are needed in a free market
Society we will pay for people with you
know I I think so the fair criticism of
gender studies is basically twofold it's
there are questions about the utility of
it in the job market but that's a very
that's a practical thing uh and also
questions about the a prudency of going
into student loan debt in order to
achieve such a degree on that basis but
this whole thing of like you know I'm
never like my car when's the last time
your car broke down and you needed a
gender Studies major you can kind of ask
that question about a ton of different
subjects
um and to be perfectly honest you can
ask them in that situation about even
hard Sciences as well like when's the
last time as an emergency you needed a
chemical engineer well no because they
work in ways that don't directly touch
your day-to-day experience and of course
you could say the same thing about when
when did you fall down and need a
sociologist or whatever hey what about
math when did you last call someone and
say I need calc 2 right away it's a very
weak criticism and they become angry and
they become dangerous and if you look
back I've the last 100 years in American
society there's evidence for that
everywhere a true evil that has taken
place in American society is always
being thought up on a University campus
it's the academics and their solutions
to problems right they come up with
horrible ideas like during the
Progressive Era they came up with
Eugenics they thought up Jim Crow
Eugenics which she's been promoting for
the last week
mushrooms right now teaching themes like
transgenderism
of course we shouldn't expect we
shouldn't respect them they know nothing
they've done nothing and yet they're
convinced of their own superiority one
of the biggest uphill battles when I
launched my YouTube channel so many
years ago was that I didn't know
anything one critique that I was getting
from journalists aside from the fact
that they thought I was a black white
supremacist these people are so smart
they're really smart guys they're really
smart
but they kept remarking on the fact that
I hadn't finished College like that was
what made them feel above me okay
Candace didn't finish University yes
it's true I had to drop out in my senior
year because Sally May had a big
collapse and my family couldn't afford
it so these elitists and their mentality
mocked me for years until I eventually
finished but they mocked me and they
felt better and smarter than me because
they have a meaningless degree and that
that makes them feel that they are of
some importance this is really a hell of
a rant huh mushrooms and when they get
understand what they
I'm feeling super inspired and motivated
by this speech and dangerous ideas I'll
give you just a few examples of some
that we are dealing with today some
things that have materialized in our
society today there is the Battle of
climate change right it's every couple
of years they change why we're all going
to die I don't know when I was in school
global warming maybe when you were in
school it was global cooling there was
the ozone layer catastrophe they told
people acid rain if you're from the 70s
you know they keep telling us we're all
going to die every 10 years we get it
right
and you wonder why is this a focus why
are they obsessed with making students
feel this fear why did they make me try
to program me when I was in high school
to watch uh Inconvenient Truth and
listen to Al Gore lecture us the planet
was going to be gone in 10 years unless
we of course listened to more governance
another one of their big big ones
obviously which I touched upon earlier
is transgenderism never thought we'd be
here never thought there's no way I do
not care if you had a crystal ball
there's no way that you could have
fathomed that you would be considered a
bigot if you said that men cannot be
women and women cannot be men that's
crazy you can't even
uh-huh
this is really bad that you would be
considered a bigot I've been called a
bigot for saying that only women can
give birth these things are obvious
obviously true and yet they are teaching
students people are earning degrees in
categories like transgenderism to learn
that no actually that's not true that
there's something other than reality
that you can that you can achieve
another category of course is feminism
my personal favorites it's just rinsing
women to believe that they should hate
men that they should reject men that
every problem and Ill that we face in
society can be described by fluffy terms
like toxic masculinity right these women
that are Marching and you look at all
these things and I describe them as
evils and things that we shouldn't laugh
at
because yes the left is radical but they
are ever so intentional they are
Machiavellian and they know exactly what
they are doing they know what all of
these things have in common climate
change transgenderism feminism we look
up and we go how why what's wrong with
the bathroom signs why why do they
choose violence every day against random
things that nobody cared about
well the truth is that their intentions
are to go after the one thing that
stands between them and absolute power
and that is the family unit
um
and so we revisit those topics and I
want you to remember this because it's
so important you will see it everywhere
and attack on the family unit you
revisit those categories and the things
that they are raising up children to
believe and you see how it destroys
families
climate change of course what they tell
children first and foremost is that it
would be irresponsible to have big
families it would be irresponsible to
have children AOC once said that she
wasn't going to have children because of
planet and climate change she thought it
was irresponsible now listen I am not
going to fight her not going to fight
her on that one
[Applause]
but think about that think about the
fact
s that Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
were awarded with an award a climate
change award for agreeing to only have
two children because it's better for the
planet
it's it's so evil it's so sociopathic
that this is what they are warning
people for
you revisit transgenderism and what
better way to annihilate families than
to annihilate bodies you will be able to
produce families you have men that are
mutilating their bodies so that they
can't reproduce you are having women
that are mutilating their bodies so that
they cannot reproduce you are having
people that are confused people that are
taking so much medication after they
realize of course
that mutilating your own body does not
change your sex it does not do that it's
just you mutilating your own body these
people become enslaved by big Pharma
they take pills to try to make
themselves happy to deal with their own
really high energy guys ultimately on
the Family
and then you look at feminism and you
look at how radical it's become in the
hatred towards men and and you see the
way that women speak of and absolutely
no respect the modern feminist has for
man and you see them confusing gender
roles again telling men that telling
women that they need to be just like men
we need to go out in society we need to
climb the corporate ladder don't worry
about your kids the government will
raise them that's why we have the
Department of Education which by the way
should be abolished
he's like we're not that good at math
let's get rid of the Department of
Education
[Applause]
women to go out and to pursue their
careers and they simultaneously tell
women that they don't need a man they
are of course attacking the family units
because those children are no longer in
two-parent households because at the
same time they're fathers ironically are
being told to act like women
be more sensitive cry more get into your
feelings right you can be just like a
woman you can you can literally be a
woman right you're telling men that and
any demonstration of masculinity is
wrong and backwards you're producing a
society where they want men to be like
dogs with their tails in between their
legs and that is because they know that
there is no society that can survive
without strong men and there is no
family that can survive without both
strong men and strong women committed to
their children
this is really bad really really bad
I guess understanding over these last
five years that it is the most important
topic my husband gave a speech recently
where he talked about cultivating a
positive and healthy interior life right
and I think about that often I think
about my household and I think that the
best way to effectuate change is to make
sure that you are cultivating a healthy
interior life you can control what
happens in your households we need more
people committed to that
friend of mine Jack besobic says if you
want to be a rebel startup lunately I'm
going to add to that and say Don't just
start a family keep a family
the interior life your family is of the
utmost importance but closely following
that of course is the exterior life and
here's what I will say and I say this
um in the bottom of my heart and I mean
this well
if you are somebody who believes that we
need to meet and sit down and break
bread with the left on these various
topics to figure out how we can come
together we don't need you
we need Fighters yeah
what's funny is if all of these folks
said we don't need the blue States their
country would literally crumble because
red states are such a disaster on
average
they're
there there is no middle ground on
transgenderism there is no middle ground
on child grooming there was no middle
ground on coming up with fluffy terms
for pedophilia there is no middle ground
and if you are offended because some of
us have the courage to say what needs to
be said we simply don't need you we
don't need to
ladies and gentlemen I think I have made
a career of fighting like hell my
promise to you always upon the stage
she's made a career of selling incorrect
information to people who don't know any
better
late much God bless you
[Music]
inspiring and Powerful Words there from
Candace Owens
in a very sort of like muted room quite
frankly
[Music]
[Applause]
all right folks Mike Pompeo I don't know
if he was canceled or not but we've got
a smoke detector issue going off and so
I actually have to go deal with that so
I think that this is where CPAC day two
coverage is going to conclude I will be
back with everybody tomorrow we're going
to hear from Steve Bannon and Nigel
farage and it's going to be you know a
completely disgusting mess thank you for
joining me there was Candace Owens let's
really all take time to process and
think through the things that she said
um because they were so so powerful and
important and we'll see everybody
tomorrow remember to follow on Twitch
make sure to like on Facebook make sure
you hit that subscribe button on YouTube
and we'll see everybody tomorrow
foreign